تناولت صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز احتجاجات
عائلات الرهائن الاسرائيليين على رفض
بنيامين نتنياهو الهدنه في غزه وقالت انهم
نصبوا خيامهم خارج منزل نتنياهو في القدس
احتجاجا على رفضه شروط حماس الاخيره
لاطلاق سراح الرهائن وقالت الصحيفه ان
المظاهره امام مقر اقامه نتنياهو دليل اخر
على الاحباط المتزايد بين عائلات الرهائن
المحتجزين في غزه منذ 108
ايام نقلت صحيفه الجارديان عن مصدر
دبلوماسي ان وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي شعروا بالفزع وخيبه الامل لان
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي اسرائيل كاتس
جاء الى بروكسل حاملا اقتراحا بايواء
الفلسطينيين على جزيره صناعيه قباله غزه
وتابعت الصحيفه ان الوزراء الاوروبيين
تجاهلوا المقترح تماما ومضوا قدما في
المناقشات الدائره ولم يتعامل معه احد
واشارت الصحيفه الى ان كاتس كان قد كشف
لاول مره عن خطه لانشاء جزيره قباله غزه
في عام
2017 عندما كان وزيرا
للنقل دعت صحيفتها ارس في افتتاحيتها الى
فتح تحقيق مستقل عاجل بشان مقتل ثلاثه
رهائن اسرائيليين بغاز سام القاه الجيش
الاسرائيلي داخل احد الانفاق في قطاع غزه
وتساءلت الصحيفه هل استخدم الجيش
الاسرائيلي الغاز السام في غزه لقتل الناس
في الانفاق واذا استخدم مثل هذا التكتيك
فهل هذا قانوني بموجب قوانين الحرب التي
تلتزم بها اسرائيل واذا استخدم فمن الذي
اعطى الموافقه على
استخدامه تناول موقع المونيتور جانبا اخر
من الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه بحق
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه حيث يكثف
الجيش الاسرائيلي مراقبه الفلسطينيين عبر
الواتساب والذكاء الاصطناعي عموما وعلق
الموقع بانه لم يعد هناك اي شعور
بالخصوصيه في نقاط التفتيش الاسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه حيث يواجه المدنيون تدخلات
متزايده في حياتهم الرقميه وتطبيقات وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي خصوصا منذ السابع من
اكتوبر
الماضي ختاما نقلت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال
عن تقرير لبرنامج التصنيف المرحلي
المتكامل للامن الغذائي المدعوم من الامم
المتحده ان من بين حوالي 600 ال شخص
يواجهون المجاعه في جميع انحاء العالم
يعيش 95 باله منهم الان في قطاع غزه وقالت
الصحيفه ان القطاع يواجه خطر حدوث المجاعه
خلال الاشهر السته المقبله اذا استمر
الوضع على ما هو
عليه
n